the juror experience i want to talk to
you about this
this when you're talking about
authenticity i want to talk to you about
have you ever seen the movie icarus i
have
dabbled i'm honestly i don't want to
watch
it entirely because i would be so angry
afterwards
it's crazy because i've lost to
russians and some of the biggest matches
of my career
and i know if i saw that i would be so
pissed off
they have changed my life in terms of
being an olympic champion being a
multiple winning more world titles
more golds they've taken money out of my
pocket
notoriety and fame away from me and
it has it'll really upset me so that's
why i've decided not to
it's a good thing to watch just to
understand the sophistication just to be
able to
let me explain to people that don't know
what we're talking about icarus is a
documentary by brian fogle
and brian was a cyclist and what he did
was he decided to do a race and it was
for for the documentary he did a race
completely natural
recorded his results and then he hired
this russian
gentleman who was a part of the russian
supposedly their anti-doping association
well he eventually as time went on it
got exposed but
he just completely lucked into this this
situation
where he hired this guy to tell him what
should i do
his name was grigory richenkoff thank
you jamie
um he is a man um
and grigory told him
exactly what he should take and when he
should take it and do this and do that
and this is how
and then he was going to do the same
race again the following year
but juiced up and see what the
difference in performance was
along the way the sochi olympics gets
exposed
that the russians had cheated and what
they had done was it was a super
sophisticated scandal where they
cut a hole in the wall and they were
like transferring the
dirty piss through one hole and and
giving them the the clean sample
to replace so they had found that there
was microscopic scratches in these
supposedly
impossible to open bottles so the
russians had figured out a way to open
these
things and have you seen the real ones
have you ever no
you've seen one of the real bottles no i
haven't seen them in the flesh you
cannot open them
yeah you can you will break them if you
open them impossible they like have this
sophisticated system in there where it's
locked into the interlocks with the
glass
so once you close it as tightly as
possible you cannot reopen it well they
somehow or another figure to work around
to get in there and open it
and when they did that they achieved an
unprecedented number of gold medals
i mean they just they dominated the
sochi olympics in russia i'm pissed bro
i'm hot because i'm hot
and you we know it like we know it pull
up
i don't even want to get into please get
into it so pull up the
i lost in the quarterfinals of the
olympic games in 2016 there's a guy
named anwar godoyev
i just want you to see a picture of this
guy you tell me was this
clean this was in rio and rio weren't a
lot of the russians
they were kicked out of rio because of
sochi they so they did
uh the most russian the most failed test
by russia in all olympic sports
first was track and field second was
weightlifting
third was wrestling wrestling was number
three out of
all olympic sports however many programs
there are i'm sure there are a ton of
sports you've
talked about it wrestling was third
they pro date
all these samples so they're getting
popping guys from 08
2012 and they're saying you know what
this guy was on a substance he was on
you know
some sort of performance-enhancing drug
so
we're going to strip of him him of his
metal
we're going to give the guy that took
fifth place the bronze medal instead but
at that point it's such a different
experience you never got to stand on the
podium
you never got to travel the world and
tell everyone about your medal
you never got to get that check that was
associated with
whatever success that you had that's
also someone taking away someone's gold
medal and then giving it to you is not
it's not the same
it's not the same so it's it's
life-changing experience that you miss
out on because these guys are being
unhealthy
and just straight up cheaters so like
i like there's a certain amount of
disdain that i have for russia
i respect them because they're
tremendous wrestlers not everyone cheats
not everyone cheats but there are those
who do
and it's well known in the wrestling
community and so at this point
we have had to just accept it and try to
beat them
you're just like you just got to beat
them because it doesn't matter
they are so powerful the ioc is so
powerful
that regardless of what they do
thomas bach and the ioc will never make
a stance
in which they will completely ban russia
so they've banned russia from the
olympic games but the athletes
that test cleanly can still compete
under a different flag
so ultimately it'd be like the
independent republic of
russia that they can still compete in
but the russian flag will not
be visible in tokyo or in paris
in 2024 you cannot compete under the
russian
national flag really done wow
so it's they've been banned from the
olympic games their governing body
russia itself so all russian athletes
will have to go through a testing
process
and then they will be able to compete on
as independent athletes
um under a different flag but not the
russian flag
and that's how far we've come bro and
like i've seen so many athletes in track
and field and weightlifting and
wrestling that
have seen other athletes get stripped
and then have been given their medals
years later
and all they get is an instagram post
yeah it's not
bro like you didn't get a chance to win
it's not cool it's not the same and it's
it's sad because it it it's the
butterfly effect
right because it messes up the the if
the ripple of the entire
bracket right so it's like you beat this
guy and then all he loses here and this
guy goes here and this guy retires
or he changes weight classes like
there's just so many things that
just happen because of this so it
doesn't make me happy
it doesn't sit well with me but at this
point like what do you do like i mean
you blow the whistle enough times but
you just gotta do what you can to to
avoid it and that the only way to do it
is beat them i think in wrestling we
have kind of like the biggest margin of
error because just because someone's in
great shape doesn't mean you can't beat
them in wrestling there's so much
precision and technical skill
that's associated with it that you can
still overcome
that steep hill but that's a problem
with the russians as well because
they're very
proficient they're freaking very good
they're freaking so technical the
wrestlers
in these you know provinces and caucuses
are insane
insane at the sport like they
from birth they are competing and
training at the highest level
it's unlike right like here you got
youth sports and you play
games and you know i mean you play
freeze tag with your buddies at practice
and you do a couple of rope climbs
you're done
like these guys are training like
olympians at eight years old
they're doing backbridge kickovers and
they're learning five-point throws and
they're just technically savvy at a much
earlier age because they're bred for
this
we think we have it hard here like
poverty here is nothing like poverty in
other countries
especially you know in like ossetia or
chechnya and all these places like it's
just a different vibe there so
they they have some amazing wrestlers an
amazing motivation too with that poverty
oh yeah it's life-changing they're tied
into the government the u.s is the only
country that their olympic team is not
government-funded
the only country in the world where
really our olympic team is funded
privately by donations corporate
sponsors
that's it we're only country in the
entire world everywhere every country
in the world has the government funding
the way that they
operate and making sure that they are
competing at a high level that's got to
be an incredible disgrace
for russia to be eliminated from the
2020 and 2024 olympics
yeah when you stand on top of the podium
bro there's a certain amount of pride
that comes with seeing your flag raised
above all else
that is a special moment and so for them
i don't know because is it pride or is
it
is it financial incentive is it
just be an olympic champion let me ask
you this what if a guy wins in 2008
okay and and and pops like they
retroactively test
the samples yeah and then is he still
capable
of competing in the future or is he
eliminated forever
well it depends i mean if
if you pop from a few years ago then
maybe i don't know maybe they prodate
your suspension and say okay every
let's say if you got suspended on that
day for two years post
that day all your results in that period
of time will probably be
eliminated but i don't think that they
would say argument but i've also heard
the argument that if you're cheating you
should be eliminated for life
for life and that that's the only way to
stop cheaters is that like
if you want to stop someone from doing
something it's prestigious is the
olympic gold medal that's a deal that's
it
i know it's death sentence but i mean
you you are you're
cheating yeah you're cheating or
cheating it's a thing like
the whole reason to win the olympics is
for glory
and for the opportunity for sponsorships
for americans and but that's why the
other countries that's why they're doing
it
yeah like well it's political glory and
when russia had it in the sochi olympics
yeah that was it's not like a
coincidence
they're following that closely bro don't
let anybody fool you that metal count
every year at every olympic games is
something that
us in the village as athletes and the
presidents of each particular respective
country
they're following that they want to win
they want to be the best of course
that's that's big to them
so above all else
some people are willing to take some
crazy chances to be successful because
they know
the incentives that will follow
them getting their hand raised but yeah
you know some people operate with
character and they're like you know what
win or lose i'm not doing these things i
think though with russia
and this was pretty clear because of
this they don't have a choice they don't
have a choice yeah they don't have a
choice exactly
what was this wrestler that you wanted
to say what was the video it was uh
anwar godoyev
just pull up a photo there's like a very
there's a photo of him he's like
super vast how about corellon i mean
corellon's one of the craziest examples
ever his parents were tiny little folks
they were like five
five and he was built like a human
panther
that's a big fella that's a guy that's
achievable
naturally with superior genetics i mean
it is possible
but if you look at any other look at all
the other russians that i've wrestled
over the last
over the last decade none of them have
that that level of stature
but it's it is whatever man like we've
exchanged matches he's beaten me i've
beaten him
um but he beat he beat me when it
counted at the olympic games and so
he does look pretty stacked he's uh he's
tough man he's a stud
and this was in rio this was in rio um
this is
is a game changer so and you are
suspicious
i'm a little yeah yeah i am i'm gonna be
honest i'm a little suspicious
i probably get a lot of heat for it and
russians probably won't be happy with it
but even if he didn't
test positive then the odds of him
using steroids up before then or using
some sort of performance
yeah whether it's epo for training to
get to where he got to
like physically yeah you know you keep a
lot of the gains
no matter what that's the hard part
about it is
within that space if you don't have a
choice fine
right you know joe listen if you want to
be on a podcast
you have to right do this right if the
government tells you
hey you want to compete for the russian
team you have to take or you can go
be a construction worker for the rest of
your life making minimum wage you're
like
i'll take that podcast give me that
right so i think
it's it's a very different vibe there
like they don't have opportunity outside
like they can't go to university they
don't go to school
russian wrestlers don't go to college
they don't go to universities and get
four-year degrees and get masters and go
on to the corporate world they don't do
that it's either
you are an olympic champion or they will
choose a job for you
and it's probably not one that's super
enticing or you will work in some sort
of organized
you know syndicate yeah it's just
different catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience